all right fashion fashion fashion my
three favorite words that was the focus
at magic the largest fashion expo in the
country and we were there to get a look
at what's on the racks this season plus
what vegas headliner made in appearance
check it out
it's three shows back now post pandemic
and we just love vegas so much and it's
like the energy just keeps building back
more and more and more we're back baby
we are back magic is one of the largest
fashion expos in the country showcasing
the latest trends and introducing new
brands and we've seen people like jay-z
launch rockwear here beyonce house of
dario i mean all the celebrities come
and launch brands here and this year
among those celebrities was a las vegas
headliner without further ado
miss katie
perry
thank you guys for waking up in vegas so
early
katy perry is known for her bold style
[Music]
so she launched katy perry collections
back in 2017 to let everyone in on her
passion for fashion um i really love
what she said this morning she said
boring shoes are for boring people and
i've always had a really colorful like
sense of style and so i really look up
to her for that for like being bold and
like being that person in the fashion
industry who's like willing to go out
there and just make a statement piece
with whatever she's wearing and so i
really love that about her the pop
singer's boot that magic was filled with
ice cream bright colors and everything
from seashells to mushroom heels
we came in and looked at all of her
shoes and they're super cute i you know
definitely need some in my size katie
for katie and her fans it's about more
than just shoes i can really identify
with that you know just being
comfortable in my own skin and who cares
what anybody else thinks you know
sometimes you just gotta be you and
that's the magic of magic allowing
consumers and business owners to learn
and grow so we had so much fun just
talking about all the tips and all the
advice to really help entrepreneurs
boutique owners brands really learn what
they need to know to set themselves
apart in the fashion industry so i'm
obsessed it's like my fashion candy land
i'm like hello i love you guys
well katy perry's residency play is set
to return to resorts world this october
5th that was awesome that's a lot of fun